everybody welcome to LED live if you
watch a lot of movies and televisions
you might walk away that Christianity's
kind of a joke these days find out on
this episode of LED live thank you guys
for tuning into our LED show where we
share the light of Christ to expose some
darkness today we're gonna get into this
topic is Christianity a joke do they
have a good reason to portray
Christianity in such a light I mean hold
on you know is it like is it got some
reason and some good well you know
Christian you know God is foolishness in
the eyes of the likud you know so
they're just like God what you know you
guys are live up man have fun you guys
are like you can't do this can't do that
I think that's why they make you know a
lot of shows make fun of Christianity
and it seems like they make fun of
everything so I would I don't want a
single Christianity out it's the only
thing that they make fun of but is there
any reason why it would be you know a
good target for secularism to really
just like slam Christianity people love
to make fun of things that they don't
completely understand so that's one
thing or if they had a bad experience
and they just want to throw it throw it
in the trash or influence other people
to hate it just as much as they do yeah
so before we get into this I do really
want to thank our patreon donors you
guys are awesome
I mean we have seen so much support from
you guys in the past few months that we
are so excited our team is growing our
work is expanding we're trying to really
put out more content so keep on the
lookout but thank you guys for your
support
and for all of the love that we have
received from you guys over the years we
are excited that you guys feel that this
show is a blessing and we'll continue to
keep putting out good content so let's
get into this
didn't you guys watch Simpsons as kids
sphere episodes
yeah what are your favorite yeah on the
box it's and everything now was this one
of your favorite shows when you were
Christian or not when I was growing up
and even into Christianity because I was
citizen really convicted about my
lifestyle anything and I just thought
it's just a joke it's just funny
entertainment or whatever you know do
you remember them making fun of
Christianity yep yeah and that's why my
parents didn't like it they knew that
the neighbor was a Christian and he was
always made as the goof ball or whatever
and they would go to church all the time
and you know I would be strangling
Barton service and homers like listening
to football during service so yeah they
really were flippant about church and
God and most all the episodes really so
I want to kind of want to show you some
of the ways that they make fun of
Christianity and it's kind of alarming
to me and will get kind of into why they
do this so Homer actually tricks Ned
Flanders thinking that he is the voice
of God and he wants him to go out and
and kill a bunch of people so listen to
this clip all these years I thought
murder was a sin then I got new
instructions from the good Lord himself
in his favorite language English and so
white bread Ned became the avenging
sword of the Lord
Peter Andrew James the greater James
lesser John Philip fatties
Heavenly Father I got you your next
divine whack job is a twofer I commend
you to kill Patty and Selma Bouvier
Patty and Selma anyone elses heart
started racing anyone can comment on
that first off like I know a lot of kids
that watch this kind of stuff and where
is like maybe there's a lot of
Christians that go okay I'm no I'm not
I'm not gonna let my kids watch that you
know I mean it it also disturbs me that
there is a lot of other kids watching
that and have you know no problem with
that
that's like mainstream television that's
I mean I don't know everything kind of
digital but that's like you pick that up
with an antenna you don't have to pay
cable at all and that that's what's
being pumped out there you know right so
here's what's happening obviously it's
not God telling him to do this and he
finds out that it's Homer that's
actually behind this whole mask do you
think this is a play on people who
actually hear voices and then they say
that it's God but it really isn't it's
just they have mental I nearly asked
that question I was kind of saving it
for later this might be stirring the pot
so so I mean I really almost think that
that what this is also doing is like
anybody that claims to have a revelation
from God or hears the revelation or god
it's just like you've now planted in the
seeds of lots of people's minds that
this is either crazy or you know it's
just a joke and it's really not Ned
Flanders
should we just adjust this right now how
to know whether it's actually the voice
of that or not there's a verse okay if
this beings not according to this word
Oh
let's find okay Jamie Isaiah 8:20 to the
law into the testimony if they speak not
according to this word it is because
there is no light in them so that would
be a way that you could be able to say
is this the voice of God or not if it's
telling you to do something that clearly
does not line up with the rest of the
Bible
it's not the voice of God that's telling
you to do some examples like I don't
know if the David Koresh and those guys
like Jim Jones and stuff like they were
sleeping with the women and stuff and
married and there was a lot of red flags
with those guys where is if the people
were really just studying the Bible I
mean this is this is a prime example of
like why you want to know what the Bible
says is opposed to just taking to what
whatever any pastor Joe Schmoe tells you
or TVs you know [__] show all right let
me if I got Patty and Selma
who's next Ned Flanders come on God
those crazy things check your Old
Testament
yeah Homer Simpson you made a killer out
of me yeah and what are you gonna do
about it I'm gonna kill you because of
You I'm language nothing matters anymore
I'm going down in my handbasket seats to
wake up Flanders there is no hell and
there is no God if there were would he
let me do this Flanders killed Homer
well I could but the big man downstairs
wouldn't like it hmm
coffee yes sir that's pretty that's
pretty crazy I mean pretty crazy for
mainstream TV to even take that deep of
a stab but what do you see in this kind
of like like a message what is the
message that's literally told people
God kills people God kills people
Shane's in charge Satan's and charts got
also lies right and crazy in the Old
Testament yeah right and that literally
he could make things better which he
said yeah I could but he doesn't you
know I mean I mean that's putting a lot
of accusations against God what else do
you see specifically speaking about the
devil his wife Ned Flanders wife is with
the devil is every time that yeah how do
they portray the devil
oh yeah like he's in charge like give me
a coffee right and he's this kind of
like muscular like suave guy right why
doesn't the media ever say you know
there's a lot of death in the world
there's a lot of pain there's a lot of
people starving in the world right why
isn't it the devil's fault isn't he the
one that kind of causes a lot of that
yeah how do they often portray the devil
in the media charismatic guy huge
theological question because on one hand
when you're saying well why doesn't
anybody blame the devil it's because
ultimately everybody knows God has the
most power hmm and God it it makes it
appear that God is ultimately the one
responsible for everything because if
you have the most power and you have the
ability to step in and change things and
you don't you appear to be the one at
fault so what's the reason why then God
doesn't step in and change I'd like to
challenge that because although yes God
has the most power would it you think we
might have quite a bit of power as well
because God we didn't have it from the
outside perspective like if you're if
you're a secular person or even some
Christians you know that's the reason
they have a problem with it cuz they're
looking at the situation is wait God is
all-powerful God is all-knowing why
doesn't God just stop all this right now
I'd say because he respects our choice
freedom of choice in answer to your
question as well I think it's amazing
that God makes the Sun Shine on the
wicked as he does on the righteous I
think it's
amazing that he is still causing
blessings to happen even if you are
literally spitting in his face to me
that is an amazing like gentlemen of a
God right people are making fun of them
and he's not just up there sapping these
people because they're like you know
disagreeing with him I think if the
rules were reversed
how would the devil react to that right
so in a huge like theological nutshell
okay this is this is a huge concept
unpack I read a book this spring about
this called The Odyssey there are
essentially rules of engagement that God
is following because this is a war and
in those rules of engagement there are
certain things that God has agreed to do
and agreed not to do you think well well
why would God even agree to like rules
of engagement in a conflict why doesn't
God just go in and just you know reset
everything right or just wave his hand
and make everything better
because God he's character and what he's
like is on the line mm-hmm and so
depending on what he does everyone will
see him a certain way and like I heard
it but I was actually listening to a
sermon this morning that was put pretty
pretty interestingly it's easy to kill a
person it's not easy to kill an idea
right and so if the idea is God is
responsible and if God is responsible
then somehow God could be evil right God
has to essentially kill that idea so how
does he do it yes he lays the devil
before kings of the world and he shows
them the result of his own line of
thinking if that doesn't happen
overnight no it takes a lot of time to
get there it takes time because you have
to see the fruit but the reason why he
does not just react immediately to this
you know arrogance and this
slamming up against him is he's
literally like if that's your
perspective then we will let our
characters speak for themselves and
there I believe there will be a time
when the devil will be shown completely
to the world and everyone in the world
is gonna turn their back on him
literally because he's the one that's
caused all of this and you know should
we do the same should we stay quiet in
this situation or are we to like allow
God to defend himself and work out his
plan and as Christians we take a step
back and stay quiet in the face of this
yeah I hope that by watching some of
these ways that they discuss about God I
want to really show what the real
accusation is against God's character
and what the real truth is against that
joke because there is there's literally
truth in every single joke right but
it's mixed with error and you know
sometimes depending on the way that
you're looking at that it's like that
joke can ultimately influence you
against or for that individual see that
cartoon we just saw with The Simpsons
and it's making Satan out to be the boss
that's really just an end logical
conclusion to bad theology because if to
be up if the bad theology understands it
like well God can stop it but he doesn't
then it makes it look like all the bad
things that are happening well Satan
just must be in charge yeah so you're
gonna see this same concept show up it's
not just the Simpsons it's it's that
that concept keeps showing up whenever
this joke is played out in whatever
media form and you'll see it in
different forms I'm sure you guys have
heard a Family Guy and it's probably not
a shocker to you that they constantly
slam God and they constantly slam once
again what God is like they're just
completely attacking that look at some
of these clips a party couldn't be any
better if Jesus himself showed up okay
everybody for my next miracle I'm gonna
turn water into fun
okay Peter your dad stinks
I'm working triple shifts and I'm still
not employee in a week how am I supposed
to compete with that hey where is he
anyway
well this will be for my fourth birdie
it looks like someone's in the zone Oh
tough break there Jesus yep
or was it well so basically you can eat
from any tree you want except this one
can we sit underneath it you know I
would just not go near it at all so
these are just a few clips but what I
wanted to bring out is like what really
are they attacking the way is who use
right so the Jesus character really is
like what using his powers for frozen
dislike right which is exactly opposite
of the way Jesus really is it means it
really speaks into perspective because
wanted to use his first miracles was to
keep the party going you know he was the
life of the show
towards the end so Wow that's and even
to the point where God doesn't want you
to go behind that tree because there's
something dirty about God right I mean
you can still see the devil's little
lies interjected in all of this kind of
joking about God if you would and it's
literally like the if you were to go ask
the serpent in the Garden of Eden and he
were to make a joke
this is how it was I don't want you up
on the tree in finest - that's right
here's a little more for a more updated
version of the Family Guy all right here
we are
it seems pretty gross I can't believe my
baby's gonna be the Son of God looks
like all those years fighting off my own
father's advances have finally paid off
what should we name him well this is
kind of like a barn we could call him
Barney yeah maybe I kind of always like
Tristan oh my god you want him to get
the crap beat out of him they will
crucify him with a name like that no no
what are you doing I want you bionaire
those names is no good look why don't
y'all just give me a list I'll ring him
up tick out and see if he picks one no
no that's the name of a champagne
no no terrible these are all just
terrible
relax God you want me to get y'all some
wine and cheeses wait what'd you just
say Jesus you want some cheese's so it's
just asked up right like the name choice
was haphazard no meaning behind it no
meaning behind it but I do want to show
you something there is a reason why I'm
showing you this terrible terrible
blasphemous stuff and as you kind of
understand okay so they're making fun of
it in cartoons or they're pointing fun
at it over here right but you see over
and over and over again no matter what
kind of comedy is really dealing with
this type of religious take they're
really kind of being extra evil about it
right you know they're focusing mainly
on Christianity I mean this is a
obviously a reoccurring joke you didn't
even touch every Simpsons every Family
Guy I mean literally the neighbor I mean
the neighbor they make fun of every time
they go to church all the time so why is
it so much focus on this how funny can
the same joke be over and over right
these guys obviously have these
characters of God and Jesus throughout
the whole series and it's just non-stop
nonsense about it but you know I I don't
see the same thing with like Mohammed I
mean they're not sitting there poking
that much like fun at that something
like that I mean this is kind of bold
for even our own country's standards
wouldn't you say the reason I bring it
up is you guys have heard God's not dead
okay so did you see it yes yes what do
you think about it okay so you're
obviously coming from a Christian
perspective right so you know this is a
movie that that what was the purpose of
the film though proofing
God is alive like Jesus or this room do
you think that they did it in a
respectful way it's debatable I know why
people won't think they think oh they
portrayed it's a Christian film that
portrayed an atheist as this like
antagonist or whatever but I do with
those atheists all the time so I mean I
thought it was pretty realistic yeah
it's actually a professor I've heard him
say right Jesus name on a piece of paper
and crumple it up my professors have
done this okay so we have a couple
atheists that join our shows right and
it has to kind of interact with some of
the comments and stuff right and give me
a little bit of the experience of that
mmm some you just can't win just back
and forth no matter what you say a lot
of us taken out of context it's not not
always the best attitude doesn't matter
how you go in there just like wall right
so I've even seen some of the comments
that you guys have put out there and
even just like I've even noticed there
there's a few people who knew that
you're just like hey I love you I love
you no matter what your perspective is
and how do they treat that generally and
whatever you said you guys are still
just crackpots and this and that right
sort of attack attack attack right so I
just wanted to point this out because I
think that in in like what you said some
atheists will say well this was an
unfair perspective in this film right so
I'm gonna take this article that I'm
gonna read to hear from indieWIRE Indy
where is kind of a website that that
comments on a lot of different films and
things like that and they're discussing
this whole God's not dead series that
came out and listen to what the little
on top of the article says it says more
propaganda aimed at people who think
that religion is under attack okay what
do we think yeah so this kind of caught
my eye because of basically the in light
of what I've just showed you with I mean
there's a lot of these are not just wore
off shows that nobody's watching them
and the simpsons is watched by a good
portion of I would say more people have
seen the Simpsons then probably have
seen God's not dead you agree with that
so they're getting that kind of
perspective more much more than the
public is getting this this
effective that God's not dead so this is
what the the person that wrote this
article was basically saying the movies
are a fundamentalist propaganda aimed at
people who are convinced that their
religion is under attack in this country
but because it doesn't exempt them from
the Constitution at a time when the
anti-semitic hate crimes are on the rise
and America is openly hostile towards
Muslim community to say nothing about
Trump's administration dehumanizing
attitude toward immigrants people of
color and the LGBT population God is not
dead contends that white Christians are
the real victims that's wrong okay
so I just want to put this out there
because this is a this is on the same
level as LGBTQ you know discussions
people have coloured discussions and
basically saying that like hey look
there's nothing being said over here
about this kind of thing like this but
there's obviously somebody just talking
about your God or whatever right now I
find that very interesting because wow
I'm innocent real genuine attacks
against Christianity and mainstream pop
culture and that's not mentioned in an
article like this at all and even
putting it on there like hate like God's
not dead is really doing a disservice
because it's not talking about these
other issues because if you start forbid
you said something negative toward the
LGBTQ community in a public film I mean
we talked about it on a discussion on
our show but if you said it in an actual
like mainstream film oh my goodness that
boycotts and protests weaken down right
well he mentioned hate crime I mean
they're these minority groups are
protected by this you know hate crime
and this hate crime law whereas I heard
a discussion where I said if some
grandma's up at an ATM machine and she
gets or no no no yeah some grandma was
that ATM machine she gets robbed at
gunpoint the cops will do their best to
find the guy or whatever and and he'll
get arrested for what he did but if it
was a homosexual at the ATM machine well
now it's not just a stick-up it's also a
hate crime
they add there's an additional penalty
to what you've just done because you've
attacked this minority group or whatever
and just tuned I wonder if you could
make that same claim with the person
that got stuck up with a Christian I
don't know I mean like yeah that's
interesting
listen know what the article goes on to
say this is the writer of course you say
most importantly the script for this
installment is or at least on its
surface
much less absurd than God's not dead or
its first sequel so he's outright
calling the other movie totally absurd
and even in later on in the article he
says wow it may seem like an irrelevant
political knock against dramatically
inert movie do you know what in ER it
means something that has the failure to
move you so it's inert it means it's
like this is the weakest like movie it
didn't move anyone at all
that it's way too houki and not a very
nice word for any critic to engage in a
serious capacity well they say that
about a lot of Christian films in
general that kind of stuff I'd say just
because there are other issues doesn't
mean that we should keep quiet about
issues you know attacks against the
Muslim community attacks against the
Christian community these are both
issues you know one isn't more important
than the other I would say that any
attack against anyone because of their
race color gender any of that I mean
even if you disagree with that gender
issue is wrong you should not attack
that person it's ok for you to have a
difference of opinion which I I can
appreciate if somebody has a difference
of opinion than Christianity then that's
fine we live in a country where we
should have the ability to have a
difference of opinion but it's
interesting to me that in this same
article where he's basically saying let
this movie was literally ridiculous
because of the way that it portrayed an
atheist and then on the same hand slam
slam slam Christianity I don't think
it's very productive and it's the way
that it's portrayed as well so Christian
jokes are in sitcoms and you're laughing
and joking but if something's happened
in the Muslim community it's published
on the news of something bad both are
bad but it's like pushed out in
different ways so that the person
watching it
in two different ways and it's both the
wrong but I think it's interesting
because I don't think that the Christian
at least the the real Christian that is
is you know really adhering to biblical
principle and so we're not going to
react that's not what the Bible is
actually ever telling you to do
so it's an easy target because this
group is never going to react you might
have other religious organizations that
if you attack them they would do
something very drastic to retaliate to
that attack because yeah there are some
that react yes you know Westboro Baptist
Church is known for their reactions on
certain topics that would be debatable
whether they are a real organization I
don't believe that that any sort of
hostile you know reaction is is
warranted at all but I think you're
right you you can't say that
Christianity as a whole doesn't react
ever there are certain sects of
Christianity that may react but I think
that's the same as applying to let's say
a Muslim I think it's it's it's not
correct or politically correct to say
that just because there is a Muslim
extremist group that will react to a
political situation that all of a sudden
all Muslims are evil I think many
Muslims are wonderful people and and
have wonderful humanity type
relationships and and so I think the
same should be applied here I think this
is kind of really blanketing this whole
idea of Christianity and putting a bad
light on it yeah I can't think of any
secular entertainment at all that
portrays Christians or God in a good
light whereas you see Hellboy Satan is
the superhero
I mean you might say well SEC its
secular why are they gonna they wouldn't
even talk about the Bible but they do
they Satan is a biblical character who's
retreated to look cool or people are
like oh I wouldn't mind going to hell
all my friends are gonna be down there
should be a party you know the highway
to hell it's like a but then it was
heaven Oh a boring sitting on a cloud
playing a harp and let's make fun of
them and they push other stuff
you know if someone is in a rough patch
hey go see the witch doctor or maybe you
should try yoga yeah you meditate a
little bit so you push those but not
this also yeah definitely we shouldn't
react maybe we should more respond Jesus
always had a response to people and he
responded in different ways I think us
as a Christian community should do more
to respond to these people instead of
reacting this is a response it's good
boy right right we're discussing it so
you brought up the Church of Satan no
reacting to a Mis portrayal of their
iconic image right here's a little clip
from et live this is the them discussing
what was happening in the satanic Church
because a particular Netflix show called
Sabrina the Teenage Witch miss put a
image of this church of Satan's icon
which is bothell met yeah I would really
miss put I mean it wasn't it pretty much
a night exact duplicate that's that's
not like a mistake yes I think what was
on the table was saying I miss put that
portrayed in the wrong
yeah they portrayed it in the road they
changed it and laughs they're putting
this in the background and the evil
scene like Netflix is chilling at
pictures Oh Sabrina has invoked an
unholy terror and 100 and a 150 million
dollar lawsuit from The Satanic temple I
don't even really want to talk about but
we're gonna talk about it anymore to to
break down the devil in the details we
are joined by FIU law professor and
author of copyright class struggle
creative economics and social media in
the social media age Hannibal Travis
Hannibal walk us through this why is
Netflix being sued well it seems like
there's a brief scene in one of the
episodes in which the characters go to a
large room where there's a statue of a
goat-headed man with small children
looking up at him and there's some evil
scheme or something going on in this
room and the statute is very similar to
the Satanic temples statue that they try
to get installed at courthouses as a
amendment message that they changed the
historic picture of the devil or bothell
met as a goat-headed man into this more
modern version with children looking up
at him so they're alleging that they
made that Netflix made an unlawful copy
of their sculpture in the show and also
used it on social media and in various
ways to create confusion between the
show and the Satanic temple so this
animal would be a case of infringement
then on their on their their likeness
and property copyright in the statue and
trademark in the statue as a something
that the temple uses to distinguish its
services from those of other religions
and temples Wow well thanks for breaking
that down Hannibal um so an iconic
symbol or image that represents your
organization as being portrayed in the
wrong light what have we just been
looking at I Jesus I just want to point
out that this was not a statue that
spoke this was not a statue that like
that told you that you know Satan's
really a good guy he's not really evil
this and that oh so that would be
totally miss portraying that what the
Satanic church like is promoting their
God to be that he's this god of
selfishness and all that kind of stuff
right so like let's say all of a sudden
this the statue was like hey you should
keep the Ten Commandments oh wow now I
can understand that you're gonna go
ahead and sue them for a hundred and
fifty three million dollars you see I'm
going with this I really really really
questioned the idea of is it okay to
then put so much slam against who God is
in popular culture
did they win the suit no I didn't it
looked into it I don't think they did
Wow I think it's hilarious 153 million
just because it was in the background
how did you come up with that number but
I think I heard they edited it out or
something so there is some kind of
compromise there was some sort of
compromise I do I do think that but I
don't think they won the lawsuit against
that that whole thing but can we go back
and get Jesus taken out
all the Simpson family guy that'll be a
task okay so that goes back to what
candy said what should be the the whole
response to this I don't think
necessarily causing a war and then you
know all of a sudden making this big
deal about it isn't necessarily how
Jesus would have responded this right
but I do think that thing I think a
silent way to deal with it is like don't
don't watch these movies don't support
this groups that are clearly against God
or whatever I mean know who you're
watching and you're supporting and
getting involved in that public service
announcement and Disney owns the
Simpsons now Disney Plus they use the
Simpsons to advertise Disney place oh
yeah that's true mm-hmm that's very
interesting so I'm gonna show you
another one and this is a coming from a
comedy Adult Swim and so not shocking
but very interesting how they're still
portraying Jesus
[Music]
so not not only does this just make fun
of Jesus but I thought I was very
interesting on this head you know the
most anticipated event right that that
people are waiting for the manner in
which Jesus is coming he comes to the
hood in not a way that people expect
member we just did a show on the Messiah
so what was the whole purpose of really
throwing out there this kind of thing
about like with Jesus is coming but it's
not gonna be like you expect what's the
purpose of the bat like a preparing
conditioning you for the Antichrist
right right right
you know cartoons were used in political
spheres way back and I think Napoleon's
day and even afterwards and what the
cartoons initially did was they took the
opposing political power and they made
fun of them that's all they were
designed to do was actually make fun of
the other side that was meant to
influence people's views of who that
entity was that's the origin of that
word you know our comics and and you
know all funny papers and all that kind
of stuff actually came from and they
were literally to make fun of political
figures and that had an influence over
people which ultimately would influence
the government right look at what we've
done with this we have now complicated
this this this comedy so to say where
this is a very real event I'm gonna
throw up what might be an interesting
discussion point and that is I'm gonna
guess that some of this maybe if it's as
much as half of it or more could be
potentially motivated not so much by
ideals of God but the way that
Christians themselves behave and the
false theology that they put forth but
they say they believe so you know give
you an example if if you're a Christian
and you you're you're you know the idea
and Christianity is Jesus is coming back
but you don't live like that
and you can see how something like this
boils to the surface is a joke and and
so many other things are like that you
know if if you're a Christian and your
your life is carousing and drinking and
partying then that reflects back on your
God and so but Jesus gets portrayed as
carousing and drinking and partying hmm
you know you know if Christians were 100
percent doing the will and the works of
Jesus I'm gonna guess that there would
be less jokes because how would how
would you make fun of somebody that
would you have this yeah that's really
out there helping loving rushing into
the natural disasters I mean yeah that's
that's that's deep I mean that is a call
for us to really say is this what the
non-christian actually views of all of
our work and all I mean we maybe we are
doing them a disservice by not
portraying yeah by not portraying who
the real character of Jesus is that's
that's an interesting question concept
of being a Christian is to be a follower
of Christ if we really looked like
Christ yeah what are we very funny
because one of the things I often throw
up at atheists when they start attacking
Christians and stuff or just God in
general or whatever I'm like what tell
me what exactly is it that you don't
like about Jesus tell me a man who
historically walked the earth for 33
years and pointed at the religious
Pharisees and called them hypocrites you
know that's something I hate these kids
I agree with somebody who healed people
and fed people and wash their feet and
prayed for them they were crucifying him
and teach him to love everyone tell me
what is about him that you don't like
this is actually Gandhi's problem to
garden said I would be a Christian
except for Christians you know
recognizing you know there's so many
inconsistencies in the behaviors of the
people that he couldn't bring himself to
be a Christian and he you think about
this this this
it's harder to home in reality and
you're in your own home mmm because if
you are not portraying the principles of
Christ and Christianity in our own home
what are your kids going to do mmm
they're gonna grow up and they're gonna
think this is a joke yeah all right a
little bit different sense of a joke but
they're gonna reject what it is that
you're putting forth and not have
anything to do with it so the world I
think just taking a step further and
said okay we've reject it we're not
having anything to do with it now we're
gonna make fun of it because it's just
stupid yeah it is interesting though
when Jesus said you know take heart
because if the world hated me they're
gonna hate you because they hated me I'm
not going to understand you because they
didn't understand me I mean if I look at
the life of Jesus who was the very
embodiment of everything we're talking
about here and the very group that he
literally called his own people looked
at his works looked at his things and
rejected him because they had the wrong
spirit I'm gonna just I've just got on a
limb here that even in the face of that
people were seeing a real representation
of God's government right there and they
were like in that cosmic joke it's all
for the right reason right so let's
let's not bring that upon ourselves for
the wrong reason mm-hmm I agree I I
definitely think that you know we need
to be way more diligent in the way that
we are reaching out to these individuals
and and they are being mean to us
find a way to keep fiery coals upon
their heads and love them today is when
I make force even walk one while I walk
to you know those that curse you he's
driving to me when he's hungry I mean
I'm can you imagine that you're the one
who's been persecuting you forever and
you'd find out that they're in a
situation where they can't even afford
food you're like dude I got you man you
need some food they're gonna be like
right right a film that came out that
was particularly alarming to me called
the invention of line so I'm gonna play
for you the little trailer for this you
can see the context of what the whole
the film is about because they were kind
of discussing this idea what if you
lived in a world where you there was no
line there was no evil so to say Oh
terrible what would that worry like yeah
yeah look at what they have they portray
this I'm a little frustrated at the
moment also equally depressed and
pessimistic about our date tonight
sure imagine a world where everyone can
only tell the truth I had a little sip
of this right there
I'm letting right now seems nice a bit
that he's where dearly about everything
I lost almost every minute that I worked
for you all the time that was hated you
you've always hated you I didn't know
that yeah a lot of people know it you
wish you could change things how much
are you going to be withdrawing today
sir $800 says here that you only have
$300 it seems our system has made a
mistake here you come today I stumbled
upon something that no man has ever
stumbled on before the world's first
life the invention of wine this is the
greatest movie ever made
okay oh did you hear the music or what
are they like it was almost like
heavenly like there's gonna lie errs and
thieves and all these people are on the
outside of the city like heaven is where
there's no lies so so have any of you
seen this movie yes no candy when did
you watch this movie he's been out a
while a preteen preaching yeah okay so
in the trailer I actually cut out all
the sexual references because there were
so many sexual references in this this
trailer that I was like oh my god is
either DVD to show this you were a
preteen when you saw this yeah and I
don't remember all the details of the
movie I appreciated the brutal honesty
really I think that's what draws me to
it in the humor but it's probably in
there but I don't really remember all
the details of it so this is kind of
like liar liar where the whole purpose
of Liar Liar was to show that in a world
that we live in there is a need to lie
if somebody says oh my god
and they're not you know I mean like do
you tell them the truth or do you lie to
them that was 17 I hope you tell me that
is what they were discussing but in this
right here you brought up a really
interesting thing and you you picked up
on something that that was very
interesting you hear this heavenly music
like clouds in a bright light clouds in
the bright light and he's the first one
that lies I want to show you the poster
okay what do you tell me tell me look at
this poster in Utah what you see in the
clouds this looks like me when I get to
heaven okay so in a world where everyone
can tell the truth you just invented the
lie okay what about this poster here
this is their poster by the way I didn't
make these I guess what do you see three
guys Wow the same burthen interesting
that are all dressed the same Wow good
job Michelle but one of them can lie
isn't that interesting
and all of a sudden you're in the clouds
you're the three guys and you that's why
there's so many subtle things that are
inside of this film that I really wanted
to show you this now proverbs I'm going
to read this to you before I start
playing some clips from this actual film
proverbs 6 16 through 19 says there show
there are six things that the Lord hates
now in them when the Bible says the Lord
hates something you better listen up
because God is a very patient and loving
God so when he says I don't like this
and then specifically I hate it this is
time for our ears to perk up and go hmm
interesting seven things that are an
abomination to him haughty eyes lying
tongue the hand that sheds innocent
blood a heart that deceives wicked plans
feet that make haste and run to evil a
false witness who breathes out lies and
one who sews discord amongst the
brothers this is one thing that's
mentioned twice two different ways
they're lying mm-hmm because what how
did the word heaven begin it started off
with a sill I about got scared sure Wow
that was what really Satan were brought
to the table that brought the rebellion
into the open was his lies and we are
dealing with the fallout from that so I
just want to put that in the in you
guys's brain
before I show you some clips from this
from this film there's a scene where
he's the one who actually finds out he
can long so no one else can lie and then
he has the idea of riding down on here
the ten rules that everybody has and
he's going to share the rules with
everybody okay believe because they
because I never heard of anybody lying
yes you sure it's ten it's not three so
I don't remember actually I think it was
close to like a number where he kept
going higher and higher I think it was
actually ten I think it is exercise I
know some things some very important
things about what happens to you after
you die everything you need to know is
written on these pizza boxes
number one there is a man in the sky who
controls everything number two well well
what does he look like tall big hands
making stuff good head of hair what if
this it is he he's a new type of
ethnicities he's a mixture of all our
ethnicities does he live in the clouds
no can we see him no it is it's higher
than the clouds too high to see him so
he lives in space not that high so then
the thermosphere sorry people I've got a
lot to get through here Khalifa just man
lives in the sky you can't see him he
controls everything cool good number two
when you die you don't disappear into an
eternity of nothingness instead you go
to a really great place number three in
that place everyone will get a mansion
what kind of mentioned the best mansion
you could think of I was thinking of a
horrible mansion what no it's the best
mansion you could ever think of not the
one you're thinking of right now
but ever whatever whatever the best
mansion is you'd like that's the one
you're gonna get
number four when you die all the people
you love will be there well they have
their own mansions yeah yep of course
everyone gets a man what if I want them
to live in my magic Wow that's fine
they'd leave their mansion they're
coming in with you work now what happens
to their magic I don't know it goes back
on the market
can we number five Oh when you die there
will be free ice cream for everyone all
day and all night whatever flavors you
can think of even bad flavors why would
you think about flavors he just said
every flavor I could think of oh no I
just thought of vanilla and skunks oh
don't eat nothing he's describing what
happens when you die which is a very
Christian ideal hmm is making fun of
some real truth everybody gets a mansion
right these are things that Jesus says
yes to pizza boxes like two tables of
stone right which is the very foundation
of the government of God right and he's
really just describing to these people
but he's totally lying
yeah so what does that tell you about
the person that knows what's going on
and is able to make those decisions it's
like all of a sudden in the back of your
mind you're seeing wow these are lies
that are told to me and even in the
context of the two tables of stones
these are lies because he really wrote
lies on those two boxes and being the
one that can lie he says there's a man
in the sky that whole concept is a lot
mm-hmm he doesn't know we have answers
to these people's questions that's right
just trust me blindly don't don't ask
questions so here's the result of his
ways that he's lying to the people
here's what happens if you do bad things
you won't get to go to this great place
when you die where will you go a
terrible place the worst place
imaginable what constitutes a bad thing
all four crimes right murder things like
that is punching someone bad yes what if
they're trying to hurt you that is fine
is cursing bad
no what about being late for work no the
spot I mean it you might lose your job
if the boss doesn't like it but it won't
affect what happens to you after you die
what about if you forget to feed your
dog well then if you forget I mean is
bad for the dog if the dog dies it's bad
but it's not I mean don't do what on
purpose don't buy a dog just to starve
it for a laugh but I mean if it was just
one bad thing do I go to that bad place
no you get three chances three bad
things and you're out look baseball
so anyhow okay so he's creating quite a
large problem mmm
right by really telling people one lie
after another and then it's just getting
worse and worse because he's now
contradicting even himself if you just
do one bad thing are you going to go to
a bad place he's also making God's laws
look like really complicated and
impossible to keep like wait a minute
what if I do this or that and there's
all these little loopholes or whatever
he has to explain right when actually
the profoundness of the ten commandments
is that everything can be summed up in
those ten things that to me is amazing
we have have you ever been to like like
court I've been to court before the
judge okay speeding tickets I'll admit
but if you were to actually sit down and
read the law books do you mean law books
there are plenty logs lots and lots and
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
and are those laws confusing oh yeah oh
my goodness this log to me is really
funny laws I can't walk an elephant down
the interstate or something crazy Wow so
that's man's mind of trying to come up
with with something that makes sense for
everybody it really doesn't make sense
for everybody and the law really as much
as we hope that it's fair if it's not
based upon literally like the
Christianity of the Ten Commandments it
really favors different groups of people
and based on how you look at the law and
how you apply it in your way
it can mean two totally different things
and what's unfair is the way that they
are really portraying that like you said
that God is really complicated in way
that he put this out that we can't
really fully understand what he's doing
and in laws that work here won't work in
other two countries but the law of God
the Ten Commandments is universal that's
the board so after all of these people
keep asking him question after question
look at how they've then began to view
God there is no hairstyle that can put
you in the bad place we've been through
this the
main ones are things like hurting people
physically on purpose okay taking their
stuff doing things to people they don't
want done murdering people on purpose
okay number nine the man in the sky who
controls everything decides if you go to
the good place or the bad place he also
decides who lives and who dies
does it cause natural disasters yes he
caused my mom to get cancer
yes did he cause that tree to land on my
car last week yeah did he kill my dad
with that heart attack yeah so how do
you think people are gonna now start to
view God right that's exactly what
happens in the crowd I say the man that
lives in the sky hiding up there doing
bad things to us why doesn't he do it to
our face needs to stop that evil before
it kills us all
listen so candy he grew up in
Christianity I don't remember this name
this wild it's not interesting yeah how
can you watch something with so much you
know you think of it as a child I mean
my kids are fully aware of the ten
commandments fully aware of like lots of
concepts about the Bible and I'm sure if
they get to the teenage age range which
they're not teenagers yet hopefully
they'll have a lot of these really
established ideas that you know God is
ultimately loving God is ultimately you
know up there wanting and desiring of
our good he wrote the Ten Commandments
for our good but yet you see this
conflicting information going in and
that's thing thank God of my upbringing
because I was actively in church we did
have discussions in the home which
family worship and all of that so
although I did get exposed to this there
was also the heavy truth coming in as
well but a picture the person that
doesn't have that and did you guys
identify the d'lai within that bit of
truth like did God do this yes did God
do that did he do it or did he allow it
yeah those are two very difference yeah
and I think somebody having a heart
attack I mean yes we are we are living
in a sinful world so you know ultimately
can God stop that which goes back to
Keith's question if God has the ultimate
power to stop it and he doesn't then all
of a sudden it's his fault oh he's
sitting around he ate a bunch of greasy
burgers all day long right clogging your
arteries but God's going to take care of
it smoking cigarettes and you know not
exercising not putting good healthy
things inside even when I story in the
Bible of the the man who couldn't walk
or was he blind and the disciples
expired okay why alone yeah why was he
born blind what did his parents do and
God said well some things are done for
my glory it was not always a negative
thing maybe that person died of a heart
attack for some greater cause that we
don't know mmm I saw that too you know
there's some is a I think there's people
that are drawn to God when they go to a
funeral because they're having to face
that this is a real thing one day I will
be in that box and what's going to
happen to me and yeah
when if I have to die to save somebody
else then it's worth it you know I mean
again I'm gonna I'm gonna go back to
this and say it's probably a strange way
to put it but I don't blame their
reaction because based on what they've
been told the reaction is logical right
you know if God is responsible for all
this pain and suffering in their life
and they haven't been explained
everything else yeah that what they're
doing is rejecting this this false idea
about God because now God is not love
this is this is almost a call for
Christianity to step up their game
and put the character of God out there
as the truth about who God is we need to
do a better job I mean I like that that
this is getting drawn out of this
conversation rather than we need to just
like you know write legislation you know
something get hundreds of signatures
trying to get him to take this down
right which is basically how they would
do it if it was on the other side of the
fence
but for us a better way of dealing with
this whole issue would be hey man get
more involved in your church get more
involved in in in preaching the
righteousness of Christ and getting out
there and being a living example of that
ultimately for Christianity I mean the
devil he's very smart and he's put us in
this what appears to be I say appears to
be a lose-lose situation right so if we
don't live as the Bible has called us to
live he's gonna sit there and poke fun
of Christianity and Christians look at
you guys
losers if we live like we're supposed to
live then we have the example of what
happened in a New Testament church the
early church what did he do he
persecuted Christianity is so hard that
people were killed so for a Christian
you're in you're in the standpoint of
like it's it's kind of the cross we have
to bear all right whether you're gonna
be made fun of you know by the devil
poking fun of it is
and pointing like it says in what's the
text it's in is it Zechariah chapter
three you know where the devil is
hurling accusations and Joshua you know
this guy's filthy rags it's no good you
know he's the accuser of the Brethren so
he's gonna sit there and poke at you
every time he can but if you live like
you're called a lid you guys try to
snuff out your life because you're
you're an example of Christ well that's
what he did to Christ even Jew the most
righteous man around or whatever it
seems like let me get him you didn't
care to go after you know the atheist
and God let him display that because at
the end of the day what was really on
display right there
it was God's character but it was also
the devil's character was on display as
well
this guy's righteous and doesn't and
this deserve any of what you did to him
and look at what you did to him do you
know what the rest of the universe was
doing looking at that going wow dude
really Satan yeah that's right so look
at look at how this whole thing kind of
ends up the man who lives in the sky and
controls everything is also responsible
for all the good stuff that happens
he's the guy that saved my life on that
fishing trip when the boat capsized yes
did he capsize the boat yeah he killed
my grandmother and left me those
millions of dollars you bet yes so he's
the one who cured my mom's cancer yeah
so he's kind of a good guy but he's also
kind of a - right but check this out
okay
number ten even if the man in the sky
does bad stuff to you he makes up for it
by giving you an eternity of good stuff
after you die as long as you don't do
any of that stuff that you mentioned
right yeah of course so it's kind of a
test hmm well that's that's everything I
know they could have taken this film
anywhere anywhere at all and here we are
wow it really goes back to do we fully
understand as Christians what the
purpose of God's holy law really is all
about I mean is it just a bunch of rules
like they said are literally God's gonna
do good things to you as long as you
follow what what his rules are is that
was that really the purpose of it
because what does that then do to our
motives for doing this right we just
want to do what God wants but I want
some stuff dude right I don't want a
bigger mansion you know I mean like I
want I want I want X Y Z or I don't or
even on the other side of the coin I'm
gonna do this because I just fear like
God's gonna do some bad stuff if I don't
do what he's asking me to do so
I want to really show a couple of verses
that really lay out what is the Ten
Commandments what is the purpose of this
is this really something that there's
and only Jesus had needed to deal with
and we don't need to deal with it all so
let's go over some of these verses
here's a New Testament verse first John
2 3 through 5 and hereby we know that we
let me know him if we keep his
Commandments he he that say if I know
him and keepeth not his Commandments
isn't what
liar and the truth is not in here one of
the things God hates one of the things
that God hates but whosoever keepeth his
word in him verily is the love of God
perfected hereby we know that we are in
him and is this far out you know are we
best friends with Liars
do we like when people lied to us God
isn't asking for anything far out of
what we expect from each other and what
I think is amazing is it's like it's
like how do we know God how do we get to
know God that's right we want to know
what that person is like right and a way
for us to know what God is like is we
can actually look at his law and say
isn't that interesting that this law
right here is the very foundation of the
government of heaven and we can take it
a step further than that it's so
important that he said I love you so
much I'm gonna cover the cost of
breaking it for you but I can't just get
rid of it because if I get gear if I
could just get rid of it and dismiss it
it really dismisses Who I am yeah you
know I could just wave my hand and move
it out of the way it certainly would
have been a lot easier but it's so
important to me that that stays in place
I'm gonna pay the penalty on the cross
and then if you go into the books that
Paul wrote you know you look in
Galatians Ephesians Colossians all those
you look through those and it talks
about the Christian walk pot actually
uses the term walk a lot and it says all
these things that were asked not to do
because they're the works of the flesh
but then all these things like the
commandments lists you know they'll say
thou shall not you know you don't murder
you don't lust you don't hate your
brother he lists out thing after thing
after thing and he says that's walking
after the spirit he's just using
different terms to describe walking in
God's law essentially and if God were to
just get rid of it
does that say why God's character well
wasn't all that important yeah you guys
can just lie and commit adultery and
steal each other stuff he wants to live
in a place like that forever I think
most any Christian would agree with you
that we still need to adhere to these
Ten Commandments right well think about
it like for a nation what makes it free
is that the lack of laws or is it the
laws I mean for an example and I'm just
saying this because this is the most
recent thing that I'm aware of is the
gay marriage law so they weren't free
before the law was in place they needed
the law to bind their marriage so it's
when the law came in that they have now
this freedom I'd like to just read this
because it reinforce the point I was
making this is from Galatians 5 it says
I say then walk in the spirit and you
shall not fulfill the lust of the flesh
this lust of the flesh idea this is bad
right okay this is this is bad and these
are contrary to one another in other
words these things are opposite walking
by the spirit blessed of the flesh
opposite things right so that you do not
do the things that you wish but if
you're led by the spirit you're not
under the law we're gonna see why now
the works of the flesh are evident which
are adultery fornication uncleanness
lewdness idolatry sorcery hatred
contentions jealousies outbursts of
Wrath selfish ambitions dissensions
heresies Envy murders drunkenness
revelries and of the like in other words
the list goes on that are similar it
doesn't stop here any continues of which
I tell you beforehand just as I also
told you in time past that those who
practice such things will not inherit
the kingdom of God so is it important
for us to adhere to detect Commandments
absolutely no brainer it's I mean um I'm
looking at these going these are New
Testament verses this is post Jesus
dying on the cross so the important part
in this is for our viewership the
important part is nobody does
that without the power of Christ in
their life accomplishing it for them
nobody everybody needs Christ working
them in their life to do those things
and I think that's where the kind of
hang up is on the Commandments is a lot
of people say you know it's legalism and
you're just trying to work your way to
heaven you're right
there's nothing you're going to do
that's gonna get you to heaven there's
no amount of if you keep this law to the
letter just like the Jews were really
good at it
that didn't save them it was more than
that and and and it's and it's not
saying that you have to do this in order
to get over to here but the Bible also
says the reverse side of this if you
want to know God you got to do it or you
will do it you will do and you know whom
your desires become as desires you have
a transformed you're a new creation you
have a renewing of the mind you're not
going to want to do these you walk in
those things because of the love that
you have for Christ for what he's done
for you in other words you don't do them
because you want to be saved you do them
because you are laws of Liberty there
you go remember the the rich young ruler
how he presented I've done all all ten
plus what else do I need to do to be
saved
Christ is like give everything away and
follow me in other words have a
relationship with me that was what was
lacking and that was the the missing
piece which is really what the Ten
Commandments is about your relationship
with God your relationship with man and
it exposed that his selfish desires were
he held on to his stuff more than he
cared about following after the son of
God so Jesus hit him right where this is
this is your issue you may have known
kept these things like you think you
kept them but really really deep down
inside you have more love for your own
possessions than you do for me that was
what Sony showed him you were saying
earlier you know there's these there's
everything can be boiled down to these
ten principles which really what you
were just saying is they can really be
boiled down to two principles
but really those two principles can be
boiled down to one principle and that is
love right Romans 14-7 says this for
none of us lives to himself and no one
dies to himself all right
in other words it's all about serving
and loving everybody else and putting
everybody else putting God and everybody
else before yourself self is last man I
wanted to read to you the definition of
hate speech I actually looked it up
because I found it very interesting that
there were so many examples of slamming
Christianity but we don't consider that
to be hate speech so I just wanted to
read to you the definition and an
abusive were threatening speech in
writing that expresses prejudice against
a particular group especially on the
bias of race religion or sexual
orientation religious alright in there
that's pretty interesting
that you know it's it's okay to
literally make fun of the Christian but
in the same breath turn around and say
that because you adhere to biblical
principles that that as all of a sudden
hate against a specific demographic
because they have a different sexual
orientation than you I just just
throwing that out there that it's a very
interesting battle that's going on
between these two groups really or their
whole fight is we want tolerance love
acceptance and tolerance but we hate the
Christian right that's not solid right
so you know I just love where this
conversation is going I do not believe
that our job is to stand up and fight
against this you know or to try and and
silence any particular group I believe
that we live in a world of free speech I
mean if this is your views you should
have the ability to express your views
and you know that's that's just what I
believe so I don't read a verse to you
from Jeremiah 29:11 it says for I know
the thoughts that I think towards you
saith the Lord thoughts of peace
not thoughts of evil and to give you an
expected end what do you think this
first means the Lord what's the Lord
wants what is best for us across the
Lord this is what I believe that that is
at the core of why God does everything
that he does he's not like these jokes
have been portraying him that he's got
something to hide or that he's really
you know selfish or he's really out for
his own means or whatever like this he
really does have our best interest in
mind and so sometimes there are
decisions that are made that are hard
for us to understand sometimes when we
when we read the Old Testament God it's
like you know it doesn't seem like it's
the New Testament dog you know what do
you think are some of the reasons why
there seems to be such a variety of ways
that God deals with us Old Testament
versus New Testament because we're a
chance to look what we give them you
know the approach is different to each
person which I'm thankful for sure I
mean in raising multiple children you
know that your approach is different
there's only one to the other so it's
the way I look at it God is the same
today as he is tomorrow and we'll be in
the same in the future and so it's like
I can understand this perspective from
being a parent I do deal with my
children in a different way
they're just going to need a different
form of interaction to understand
concepts whether it be discipline or
whatever but you're the same person and
your love for both of them is the same
exactly and so the way that I deal with
them they may look at it and say that's
not fair and you're viewing this to me I
don't know if you hear this from your
kids I hear it for my kids you didn't do
this to this one but you did it to me
and but but it's really giving me a
perspective to understand how God
operates as well and I think that
there's contextual things in the Old
Testament that we don't understand
because of lack of history or whatever
we're not fully grasping what was going
on back then we're looking at this
through the modern eyes and stuff and so
we look at and we go hey that's just
ridiculous for how he reacted back there
but there's a lot of things that we we
would think are crazy
about what happens today as opposed to
back then so people used to kill their
children magnetically right right it's
just a different right for I know the
thoughts that I think towards you as if
like here it is you know here's the
playbook out and it hasn't expected and
this is guaranteed if you follow it step
by step and I have nothing but what's
best for you but it's your choice it's
your decision go by the rule book or the
playbook and get that expected end or
you can have you know the other thing
that you choose
looks like God has the best intentions
and it's right out there for you to to
view and no you expected and I think
it's important to remember that the
Bible doesn't record every single act or
every single thing that God did ever in
history that'll be it gives us examples
and things that were done we have to
take God for who he is and apply that to
all times and places for example so the
Bible says the Lord is not slack
concerning his promise as some count
slackness but is long-suffering - or
toward us not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance if God is like that now God
has been like that in the past and we
can take for example like the story of
Jonah Jonah was sent to animation that
you know he and his eyes deemed wicked
and worthy of destruction and we see
examples where God did destroy nations
but he did it if you notice by and large
he did it on like an executive
governmental level he didn't do it like
on a personal level like you need to go
kill that person and you need to go kill
that person God is not like sending
people out to be assassins he's saying
no I'm using a nation to execute divine
justice with this verse it tells us that
God somehow some way that's not recorded
or we don't understand it was reaching
out to those nations trying to get them
to come to repentance and when they did
not then God said okay you've reached to
the limit and now this has to be done
the wages of sin is death it's always
been that way it will always be that way
one way that we can see that example is
when God actually told the children of
Israel to go through and not touch
certain people that their their iniquity
had not filled up the cup to its level
and so that's God saying I'm still
working with these people right here I'm
not going to allow them to to be
executed at this point and I and I think
you know in some cases it was 400 years
plus that God was patiently waiting for
these people but I think in the end of
time we will see that even if God gave
them thousands of more years they
wouldn't have chosen him and that
judgment was passed at a at a point
where it didn't matter what God would
have done they literally wouldn't have
turned around he also have the example
of even Israel as God's people they
still suffered for the things that they
did and God used other nations to bring
judgment upon them right some of them
died and we're putting that risen and
had horrible things happen let it float
in the street yeah yeah here's where
this is kind of really going though why
I wanted to start out this conversation
really about you know these things that
are for lack of a better term they're
very super blasphemous right I actually
seriously even have a hard time even
wanting to play this kind of stuff do
you do you feel uncomfortable I hope you
feel uncomfortable I mean if you're
watching some of these clips if you
don't feel uncomfortable there's a
problem okay so the reason why I wanted
to play this for you was because I
believe that in the very end when we
speak of the mark of the beast or the
Beast power or this whole thing that's
coming to accumulation in the end of the
world the Bible says in Revelation 13
this is where it's talking about the
Beast is describing the Beast and
starting with verse 3 it says and I saw
one of his heads as it were wounded to
death and his deadly wound was healed
and the whole world wondered after the
Beast and they worshipped the Dragon
which gave power unto the Beast and they
worshipped the Beast saying who is like
the Beast who is able to make war with
him and there was given unto him a mouth
speaking great things and blasphemies
and power was given unto him to continue
forty and two
and he opened his mouth in blasphemy
against God and blaspheme his name and
in his tabernacle and them that dwell in
heaven so where this whole thing is
basically confessed during and
cumulating to is a place where the devil
is going to be instrumentally involved
in whatever this beast power is in the
end of the world right and we know that
it's going to have a heavy blasphemous
connotation is gonna be given a mouth to
speak blasphemies the media is a
platform a mouth and you will to speak
blasphemy so think about this when
mainstream Hollywood is constantly
blaspheming God constantly putting this
idea of it's a joke he's just nothing
good he's just this other guy and
they're constantly trying to change this
could that be priming the public to
someday accept this type of a mark of
the beast well that's good again is the
final final cumulation of Satan and his
whole organization that he has which is
gonna be of a religious order in the
very end of the world he's going to use
a religious order that's gonna speak
blasphemies against God is it possible
that all this media is literally
preparing the masses or people to
literally understand blasphemies against
God or literally to go along with
blasphemies against God because you know
what one thing that if you hear
something over and over and over again
you know what it does it knocks down
your defenses and so I see a problem
even if you're a Christian and even if
you say I totally believe in God and and
I this is not gonna influence me
whatsoever I like the Simpsons I'm gonna
watch The Simpsons and ha ha ha it's
it's that's making fun of their little
Christian neighbor whatever likeness you
know what that's doing to you over no
it's practice you see that you laugh you
see it you laugh you don't take it
seriously you see you left less when you
spoke in oh it's nothing you laugh I
think the strongest point
that we can have if we really honestly
love God and and really want to to do
his bidding is to basically say you know
I don't I'm gonna turn it the other way
that's practiced I'm not gonna engage in
this
I'm gonna turn it off I'm gonna walk the
other way if they're making fun of God
in this I'm out so charge the charge
brothers and sisters will do it recharge
me tear them that's right so I hope that
you guys you know got a little blessing
from this this was not just to show you
look the whole world is against
Christianity I think there's some really
great things that came out of this
discussion actually but I wasn't quite
anticipating I actually loved what what
Keith brought out in this whole
discussion about hey look we are doing a
disservice in portraying Christ and and
that is something that you guys can
really hopefully take to heart listen if
the world is not seeing a clearer
picture of who God is then that's a call
for us that's a call for us to a get
involved in churches get involved in
supporting ministries whether it be
working for them financial donations
whatever you want to get involved in
your local church level brothers and
sisters the time is coming that this
beast power is about ready to step on
the scene and I believe that it is gonna
be a time of such confusion that you
don't even want these little seeds
planted in your mind at all so learn to
turn things off learn to turn the other
way learn to disengage from that media
of the world that is literally putting
our God in a false light and learn to go
out and show the world who God really is
thank you guys for watching and we hope
and pray that you like this video
subscribe to our channel we got a lots
of videos like this coming out and thank
you all once again for Tunde we'll see
you guys next Friday
[Music]